so lucas hilton dropped two trailers on
us today i was going to do reactions but
i honestly i don't have the time so
here's some quick thoughts and or i have
honestly very little thoughts i had a
hard time completely parsing the vibe on
it it wasn't what i expected and since
it wasn't what i expected i don't really
know what to make of it yet i'm still
hopeful for the show
um but i don't i don't know it kind of
left me a little bit cold willow willow
i liked quite a bit now granted i have
nostalgia for willow as a property uh
more so than cassie and andor i mean i
like rogue one but i didn't see that you
know during the age when i can be
nostalgic for that time now but i liked
the vibe of willow i'd love seeing
warwick davis again i like the bright
colorfulness like i i'm fine with dark
fantasy i'm ready for some light and
colorfulness and it even they even had
the theme that wonderfully cheesy theme
music came up yeah
yeah i definitely have the two i'm more
excited for that